What do we know about witches?
The woman with
magical powers and spells,
in a pointy hat, with a broomstick
and a black cat.
But behind this stereotype
is a long, dark history
of torture and persecution.
Much of what we think we know
comes from the
16th and 17th centuries,
and especially the work of the
witchfinder Matthew Hopkins.
It led to the deaths
of around 100 people,
and still has echoes
in our lives today.
In the 16th and 17th Century,
people in Europe were living in what
historians call a magical universe -
a realm where
it was implicitly accepted
that God and the Devil were real.
Life was hard in England at the time.
People were often hungry,
angry, and fearful.
Most people lived in small
rural communities,
and between 1530 and 1630,
the population doubled.
There were plague outbreaks,
and a “Little Ice Age”,
causing harvests to fail.
Everyday misfortunes
could be interpreted
as either a punishment from God,
bad luck, or the act of a witch.
It was widely believed
witches could raise storms,
destroy livestock, drive people mad,
or even kill them.
Witch trials followed legal process,
and acquittal rates were actually
relatively high.
Only 22% of those tried
in South East England were executed.
While burning at the stake
was common across Europe,
in England, witches
were usually hanged.
In the 1640s, during the chaos
of the English Civil War,
the witch-hunter Matthew Hopkins
appeared on the scene,
along with his associate,
John Stearne.
Known as the Witchfinder General,
Hopkins would ride into villages
in East Anglia,
often invited by concerned citizens,
and listen to their suspicions.
With his assistants, he would search
for the "witch's mark"
or "teat" where familiars
were thought to suck blood.
Familiars were thought
to be a witch’s companion,
half-animal, half-demon.
They included toads,
ferrets and cats.
He had suspect witches
watched for days,
to see if their animal familiar
would come to them.
In reality, this was
sleep deprivation,
designed to break
suspects into confessing.
Hopkins also used the swimming test.
A suspected witch’s toes and thumbs
were tied together
and they were
submerged in water.
It was thought a witch would float,
rejected by the pure water,
but the innocent would sink.
Women were considered at the time
to be more vulnerable
to temptation from the Devil.
Some women were particularly
vulnerable to accusations,
due a lack of protection
in a patriarchal society.
And although most of the witches
accused during the Hopkins
witch-hunt were women,
in other parts of Europe,
greater numbers of men
were persecuted as witches,
and men were caught up in
the Hopkins witch-hunt too.
The elderly clergyman, John Lowes,
was accused of witchcraft in his
town of Brandeston in Suffolk.
He was examined by Hopkins
who "found" two teats on his head
and one beneath his tongue.
Under torture, he confessed
to having six familiars
which he had allegedly ordered
to sink a ship, killing 14 men.
Although he later retracted
this confession,
on August 27, 1645, he was
hanged in Bury St Edmunds.
Yet opposition to Hopkins’
witch-hunt was growing.
People began to condemn his methods.
His influence waned and,
after an illness,
he died at home in August 1647.
Overall, around 250 people
were investigated for witchcraft
during the Hopkins witch-hunt,
and about 100 of these
were ultimately condemned.
The Hopkins witch-hunt
was a brief and tragic period
in the history of England.
Many people in the
16th and 17th centuries
believed in the
necessity of witch-hunts
to protect their communities.
But these persecutions
can also be seen
as a case of blaming
vulnerable people
for the difficulties of the time.
We live in a very
different world today,
but has the witch-hunt
mentality gone away?
We still have a tendency to accept
easy answers to complex problems.
Social media fuels
both conspiracy theories
and the public shaming of others.
Fear and uncertainty
is still being used
to scapegoat vulnerable
sections of society.
So while the context
may be different,
witch-hunts, it seems,
are alive and well.